[Music]
I've realized I'm weird I'm especially
weird when it comes to food this is a
picture of my kitchen cabinet it sort of
looks like I'm hosting a gathering for a
chocolate fictional characters I'm not
and no I'm not super prepared for Easter
this Bunny's been up here for almost a
year what else makes me weird I scrape
out every last grain of rice from a bowl
I eat I spend extra time chopping around
the end of an onion and I must have
smelled the milk in my fridge at least
six times this morning
to see if I could still drink it versus
having to pour it down the sink I wish I
knew why I did all these things it's
certainly not because I didn't have
enough to eat as a kid instead I don't
know I feel some sort of obsessive
obligation to be mindful of the food I
eat to respect where it came from and to
not waste any of it unnecessarily to me
food is sacred which is why when I found
out about the amount of waste that still
exists I was heartbroken I found that
the equivalent to a hundred and sixty
five billion dollars is thrown away in
the US every year from food that is
otherwise completely edible a hundred
and sixty five billion dollars imagine
what else we could do with all this
money this led me to ask where on earth
does all this food ways to come from and
the answer is sadly from pretty much
everywhere it starts in the fields
consumer demand may change from crops
are planted to when they're harvested
which means that stores and distributors
no longer one or the food that's been
grown often this can't find a new home
at short notice and is left to rot on
harvested in the fields
once harvested food is taken to
facilities where it's sorted here
estimates vary but between twenty and
fifty percent of all produce is simply
discarded due to blemishes or being miss
shapen now I don't know about you but
once a carrot is cut up in my salad or a
strawberry is blended in my smoothie I
don't know and I certainly don't care
what it started looking like pausing
here for just a moment the fact that so
much of our beautiful fresh produce is
simply thrown away because it's ugly
not only astounds me but it also angers
me luckily I'm not the only one who is
completely outraged by this and there
are startups that will rescue these
apparently ugly vegetables from going to
the landfill and will send them to your
door instead check out imperfect produce
calm if you two are not judgmental about
how your mashed potato started looking
continuing our journey through the food
distribution system we've reached the
cities where the food is set to be sold
and hopefully eaten here some goes to
restaurants and the rest to grocery
stores and unsurprisingly food waste
exists here as well but this is the step
where you and I everyday consumers can
have a daily impact let's start with
restaurants a little fun factor in start
here is that I'm British and one of my
favorite things about moving to the US
is the fact that all restaurants no
matter how fancy or cheap will have to
go containers the fact that I love to go
containers and the Associated leftovers
really shouldn't surprise you at this
point as you know I'm weird with food
but even for me there are some times and
some dishes that I just don't want to
have again or don't keep well as a show
of hands how many people have thought
about taking food home from a restaurant
but decided that they didn't like it
enough to want to bother
and then for those of us who have
brought food home with the best
intentions of eating it how many of you
have ended up throwing these leftovers
away uneaten yeah this happens to me a
bunch too I guess it comes with the
territory of taking pretty much
everything with me fundamentally I
believe that the mass prevalence of
choco containers connects with one of my
last favorite things the portion sizes
in the US and I don't want to give the
impression that this is an issue unique
to the US but with us Millennials eating
out more often than any generation
before us we ought to be more aware
about how much food waste we generate
from restaurants hearty portion sizes
shifting now to think about food waste
in the home I'd like to share another
story with you all not long after coming
to business school I decided I was going
to start snacking healthier so I bought
a big multi pack of yogurt
unfortunately chips or chocolate or
always far more appealing to me than the
yogurt in my fridge so as the expiration
date started looming towards me I
realized there was no way I was going to
be able to eat it all but what was I to
do we're taught as children not to
accept candy from strangers no person in
my apartment building was going to want
yogurt from the random girl down the
hall
eventually the expiration date passed
and I begrudgingly picked up the yogurt
that was left and flinched at the thump
it made when it hit the bottom of my
trashcan I'm going to go out on a limb
here and say that you all most likely
have had experience throwing away food
that's not too dissimilar to this but
I'd like to rewind to the pot in my
story where I thought it would be too
weird to give the yogurt away why is
that so weird that shouldn't be weird
and as it happens a lot of people don't
think it actually is there's a start-up
olio that facilitates peer-to-peer
sharing of food
at this time they've shared over 400,000
food items and have an exceptional
marketplace clearance rate what this
means is that people want free food and
they're prepared to accept it even from
a stranger
the issue that olio has found is as much
as we're prepared to accept food we tend
not to think a food that we no longer
want as something that others may still
value what I've realized we need to do
is reframe the concept of sharing food
we live in a sharing economy which are
apartments with strangers through a B&B
we share our cars with others through
uber and left why not share our leftover
or unwanted food with neighbors and
friends the second thing we need to do
is be more honest with ourselves about
how much food waste we actually generate
and how we can be a part of the solution
no one likes to think that there are
problematic waster and it's much easier
to think that the issue of food waste is
so big that there's nothing we can do as
individuals to impact it but I'd like to
challenge this concept I'd like you to
think about the other issues that seem
too big for individual action to matter
recycling energy consumption and climate
change even civil rights movements yes
there is more that we can do in each of
these areas but we've seen the cultural
shifts that have happened surrounding
them and they all started with
individual actions that combined have
been effective what I hope to leave you
all with today is a greater
understanding for the food distribution
system and the associated waste that
goes along with it
I hope I've given you insights that make
you pause appreciate the food you have a
little more and perhaps think about ways
that
you can reduce your own food waste maybe
just maybe I'll have persuaded some of
you to start being as weird with food as
I am join me let's all be weird together
and make weird the new normal thank you
[Music]